I think this Barbie person there's some there's some avenue of
peace we could find and they're not they're not going down that
road I guess.
I will say I will say I have no heat for until Shimu finishes
his next Heck video. Okay. Well, okay. Because Nick's going to
do this. Nick's going to go Oh, I don't know. I think I think
Willie realized that was just a bit too unreliable, you know?
I mean, people gave Dan maybe a little bit too much charity,
but we all gave Dan too much charity, so I mean it's fine. I
like that his argument isn't I would never do this. It's I didn't
even do anything this time. I didn't even do it. I believe I
just untimed him out for something like this very recently. I
just got this randomly. I've been lying. What the he threatened.
It was Riyle who did the throw apparently. Well, you unfortunately
have my It sucks cuz I don't want Riyle timed out either. But
unfortunately, yeah, if people are breaking the rules, they got
to go.
Will you please just respect the fact that it's not a vape a
medicine anxiety pin? Okay, that might be me. Is this That was
a very That was a very weird ending to Yeah, this one seems fake.
It's a anxiety pen. Get it right. What flavor is your
What did you say, Kelly? Sorry. What is an anxiety pen? I assume
it's just like a vape. A CBD vape or something, maybe. Are they
still No, I didn't watch that. I have no interest in that. Sorry,
I talked over you, Gang, Kelly. My bad. I did not. I said, "Aren't
they still vapes anyway?"
probably the difference. Oh, he's back. Dude, the the anxiety
pen thing is so annoying. It's a It's a bit It's It's Yeah. No,
I was just saying it's Dude, the when he said when he said
pen
final
for the billionth time, will you please he can't mention that
he vapes?
Oh, I see. Maybe TikTok. I don't know why like so many people
have just like Yeah, I know why so many people have like just
bed onto him and been like, "Oh my god, look at this guy freaking
out about his about his vape calling an anxiety pen." It's like,
"Yeah, he's joking." And it becomes very obvious he's joking.
Just respect the fact that it's not a vape. A medicine anxiety
pen. As soon as he knows that, oh yeah, it's just a bit like
obviously a bit. Maybe it's because he freaks out of other stuff.
How does the CPS? It's kind of funny. It's not like the worst
bit I've ever seen. I don't know. Why are we judging this bit?
It's not the worst bit I've ever seen. It's pretty bad. Oh, did
you see Did you see Dean's audition to get back on the America
tour? Oh, what the doxing thing? Yeah, like obviously he's just
engaging in Destiny and Dan's favorite behavior so he can get
back on the America tour. I would assume. Guys, we got to dox.
We got to dox this guy and call call CPS. Okay. Really important
that we get this guy's kids taken away right now.
Right now. Badly acted, dude. Yeah, you'd think these people
would be a little embarrassed getting out acted by Nick Fuentes
all the time. Oh,
we could do that. I didn't prepare a lot of content for stream.
Hold on.
you just want to watch the divorce stream. You just want to go
back and watch it. Not the whole not the whole thing maybe, but
not the whole thing, but can watch like a little a little bit.
What is this divorce stream? The streams that Fentes did after
Destiny's divorce was announced. Why did you think of this recently?
We're doing something with Auggie and Yeah, we watched this clip.
Okay, there's like Yeah, this is this is the first bit. There's
like two bits in this one and then we'll go to the other one.
I might watch some like a bunch of the other one to be honest.
The one that as well. Yeah. Yeah, the the other one. The update
one. I remember I didn't watch this cuz I was like, "Oh, you
know, probably be weird to stream this."
Like uh when I Why did I I I thought it'd be weird to stream
this. I was like, "Oh, it' be weird to stream this." Well, well,
I'm like embedded in DGG. Like, I think I just probably banned.
I It was like my third stream ever. So,
anyway, cuz I think I was covering like Nick Fuentes stuff when
I was streaming, too. Supposed to be Keeping Up with Fentes content.
I don't, but I will again. Yes. No. What's the What's the main
What's the main song? That could have been there. Hold on. Oh,
what could have been? That's brutal, dude. That hurts
That hurts me. Oh no. Kelly is blocking Nick on the on the
Oh. Uhoh.
Unacceptable. Unacceptable.
Hold on. We'll get We'll get Kelly back in here. Over here. There
we go. Wow. Let's just play it with no audio. Look at this. No,
come back.
I miss you. This melt time. Remember Mel time?
It could be just like it used to be. Mel time. It's Mel time.
It's Mel time. Mel, why did you have to leave?
Don't leave me. That's terrible. That's terrible. That's terrible.
Yeah. Anyway, why does uh why does Dean get outacted by this
like staunch conservative alt-right commentator? Okay. Why is
this guy more of a theater kid than anybody in the left? It's
up. Okay. Hold on. Next bit.
Uh, whatever. Get a kid mustache. Breaking bull.
Definitely not gay. Yeah, look at this merch.
Oh, disavow.
Dude, your merch sucks. Really? A black hoodie with a black zip
up with your logo? What is this? merch for a school for the most
le
if you're like a 27y old [__]
as you go like I hate Christians you know this is like this is
the mask that you would wear you would you would zip this up
with a ball of lava and a shotgun
this is like trans
this is a uniform for trans school dude your merch is look at
this gay little icon meme tix's merch is so much cooler That's
why she laughed with a cool logo in the
Uh, so this gets so much better when you know that the m one
of the biggest things that Destiny off was the fact that when
Molina landed when they're she's coming back to talk about do
their like last therapy session and try to make the relationship
work. She actually got off the plane with wearing a memeix hoodie
when she met him at the airport. And he never goes to the airport
for anybody by the way. He makes everybody get Ubers from the
airport. He went to pick his wife up at the airport and she came
off the plane in a memeix hoodie.
this merch is fire, dude. This is actually cool. This merch is
actually sick, bro. Are you serious right now?
That may be the one.
Dude, that's tough. That tough as hell. He's actually st Look,
he's got the pearls. This guy, Dude, this guy's got the freaking
pants. He's got the He's got the rack. He's got the pearls. The
side, the middle part. Suck my dick. I killed myself. Hard to
believe, but this works. This this cleansed up in Stockholm,
okay? And you look like a bum, dude. You're wearing freaking
trans school merch and you look like a greasy bum. Of course,
she left you, dude. That's cool.
Yo, is this No, different girl. Dude, this guy's a Rizzler. He's
clearly got a type. He likes his buff. She's got that
Believe in yourself. On your way. Believe in yourself. on his
way to steal your wife. On his way to threat to commit suicide
if you don't divorce
if your wife doesn't divorce you.
POV I'm on my way to threaten to commit if you don't divorce
your husband. Dude, we're so lucky that this guy is not allowed
on YouTube or kick or like any platform basically. Okay, we just
get to stream because this guy's not allowed. Thank god. Thank
god. And it works. It works. Keep him out. POV, I'm on my way
to successfully gaslight your wife into leaving you.
So awesome. But let's get I don't like that song. We need a different
song. What's like a good What's like the Chad is to go not beating
the Andrew P song. What's that one? Just giving it in now. Is
funny. Okay. I've literally never once said Nick Fentes is not
funny. You will never ever find me saying that anywhere. H
I believe I when I was originally confronted with bad empanada
hunting down uh Hila Klein or some IDF secretary in a video game,
I basically just said he stole it from Nick Pentez and Nick did
it better. So or what's the CS in the club? Huh? Play his music.
Does he have music? What is this?
I guess it's this. Why did this come up? I don't need
He's on his way.
Give it to me. Everybody put up their hands. I get a
Never go see the day that I got the
me on my way to threaten.
You don't leave your husband. I'll myself. I swear I'll do it.
I didn't even notice he's got the same movements as in the other
clip. Somebody link me the other clip. I don't have it right
now. Hold on. I swear. Raise your right hand
clip channel. We've given in to the idea of making any actual
content. We're just watching
Nick Fuentes watch Tik Toks. Your husband
and it worked. Here, I'll help Kelly. I'll help alleviate Kelly's
stress. I'll move her off screen. I get it. I get it. Don't want
to get Don't want to get clipped in that one. Yeah, I get it.
I understand.
We'll wait until we finish the segment back. Sounds a bit boring.
What do you mean boring? This man's comedic gold. Okay,
he won. Dude, meme tick one. Meme tick
Okay, there's one other clip that is way better, Kelly. And then
uh well, way better. No, it's it's better than these ones, but
it's not way better. There's one more clip that I got to watch
really quick and then
go do something else. Okay, we can go do something else after.
Do we know what we're doing next? Queenman, you got any content
ideas?
Oh, we'll figure it out, Kelly. We'll figure it out. Every single
attempt like Oh, right. Every single thing I'm like, well, do
you have a log for that or That's cor Dude, I love this is so
Did I tell you,
man? Did I tell you this is going to be a delicious feast or
what? This is like a bucket of KFC right now. This is like a
double, triple, extra large cheese pizza and a bucket of fried
chicken and a 2 L RC cola.
This is it. This is good.
This is good stuff.
Did you catch that? He said that he's like Neo from the Matrix
and he's in bullet time dodging his ex-wife's lies. Imagine like
how
up your life had to be to utter that sentence
on a public live stream. Like this is a picture of your life.
Let me take a picture of your life. You're 34. It's so true.
It's just obviously true. And somehow you be in like a community
where people don't understand that and and they forget that that
like it's just the most like totally antisocial
behavior that you could describe. years old. You're on your second
failed marriage. You're on a live stream saying, "I learned to
dodge my ex my ex-wife's lies like Neo from the Matrix."
This is like a little picture. Let's take a screenshot.
Saved to camera roll. Saved to files. You were there. I was definitely
there. It's like a little screenshot of your I Why do you think
I just said the last thing I said? 34 years old, second failed
marriage.
You're on a live stream talking about your marital problems now
that I've become like Neo and I could do bullet time and see
her my ex-wife's lies in real time. That's like how do you how
do you become that person? How? Because let's avoid that at all
costs. Who would want to be on a public live stream saying I
learned to dodge all my ex-wife's lies? You know how like bitter
that sounds? That's brutal. Let's let's rewind that part. I want
to watch that part again. every single like pivot. so funny seeing
your chats glazing Destiny in old vids. Was that really often?
I feel like a lot of time I'm like correcting or giving my opinion.
But there are some that I know I'd have the wrong opinion on
though that I'd be like, "Oh, this is like actually disgusting."
I'm trying to think. I feel like they should strike me off the
top of my head. Can't can't think of it. But all right. All right.
All right.
Jesus. I think we're going to go to Gaming for Hope.
What? That's not the name. I Gaming for Hope. Oh, man. I just
got the name totally wrong, didn't I? No, that's his name. Is
that his name? Okay. Yeah, I think we're going to Gaming for
Hope. I have not watched any of his stuff.
It's pretty funny. Okay, hold on.
It's just like little caption. I just if I had like something
else going on right now, I would probably do it, but let's see.
Anyway, yeah, we'll we'll see. I have like none of Let's address
these allegations of
I do have a question. if anyone in the chat knows the answer
because I genuinely don't. Um, why is Destiny learning about
CO? I'm just Yeah, I'm just wondering if they could tell me because
uh he was learning because all the conservatives are convinced
is the lab leak theory is like 100% now. So, I guess he's trying
to debunk that. I would assume. Do you know what the lab leak
theory is? That's America's biggest problem right now is that
people believe that CO was leaked from a lab. I can't think of
a bigger problem. though it's obviously because he argued heavily
against that in the past and he hates the fact that he might
be broadly considered wrong on it. So he's trying to reinforce
his position. But uh yeah, the labing theory is just the idea
that basically there was a lab in Wuhan that was performing gain
of function research that was funded by in part by Fouchi that
the American government knew about and uh China basically due
to a lack of safety protocols or intentional leaking allows CO
to get out of this lab while they were engineering it.
Okay. But so that's why he was learning about what gain of function
but gain of function is just a um mutation in a gene.
Well actually gain of function is something that happens after
a gene mutation because you can have loss of
yeah anyway it relates to channelopathies usually or something
those these diseases but why is that suspicious? Why is a lab
studying gain of function
or there's there's a few other points to it where basically um
there was there is like evidence of like a lack of safety protocols
and a there were several workers that got sick with like co-
like symptoms like weeks or months before it became prominent.
So there's like a lot of suspicion around I don't know how much
it is proven or what but these are the talking points I've heard.
So there's there's other points of suspicion they bring up, but
I don't actually know how legit that is. The the suspicion part
I understand, but what I didn't understand is why he was spending
hours desperately trying to learn what gain of function is
or how that relates to the COVID conspiracies in any way. Well,
because because it's a gain of function. The idea is that they
were doing gain of function research
um on on
uh what is it? SARS or whatever. So,
there's like some I can't remember what all the talking points
are, but there is like something about the types of gain of function
research you can do or what they said they were doing or something
and them not being honest with the public about the type of research
is being done in that lab or something. It's all I I'm not a
conspiracy guy, so I don't know all the [__] Well,
is the is the implication they were doing they were mutating
genes themselves in animals or something? And
I think you were supposed to edit viruses to turn them into like
to make them more like contagious or something. and there's like
a site or something that makes it seem like oh they made it they
modified it genetically like they actually spliced DNA in to
make it more likely to spread to humans or something right I
think that's like
it still doesn't make sense why he was spending so many hours
learning what gain of function is well it would make sense if
you actually want to know what why whether the lab theory was
true but I feel like it is but he doesn't know what an ion is
if he doesn't understand the basic fundamental building blocks
of the things that he's studying He listening to hours of 38
is a fine time fing time to learn at 38, Kelly. Okay, stop hating.
If you don't know that fluoride is an ion and
how ions interact within like a I'm guessing these are voltage
gated ion
I'm not sure what the gain of function was being studied, but
I don't know. But it's just I feel like if you don't know the
basic things, what what good is he going to do? But also I'm
I was just curious cuz I didn't watch any of it. Trying to learn
to understand he's not he's trying to learn enough so that he
can argue that other people are wrong. He's not okay. Even if
you want to do that, you still need to learn the basic stuffs
and like how that's applicable and what it means in a broader
context. Otherwise, it's just like you're listening to nonsense.
So, I don't know how you So, Jason, this is a bad video to start
on with Gaming for Hope. I started here and I I wanted to go
to another video cuz I regretted it. Oh, well, I Yeah, I totally
Let's go. Why does she know this chemistry stuff is also chemistry?
This is like medicine related. Um, ariththroalgia, which is the
illness I have just trauma.
Okay, that's cool. I was talking. You know what, Kelly? Hold
on. Uh, my bad. I want you to tell me about ariththroalgia. I
will leave moral on the back burner for now. To yap so much and
you never once complained or were mean to me
and I been here.
Okay. You asked me to be here. I'm We love Kelly. Can I ask you
in a chance?
I promise I actually don't mind you talking about this finishing.
I just It's such a funny joke to make. I can't not do it. So,
I just I laughed Yeah. I just think it's mean. Okay. I will endeavor
not to do that exact thing again. Wait, tell me what's mean so
that I can actually understand what I did wrong so that I don't
try to because I was enjoying myself talking and then you just
interrupt me and then you make fun of the fact that you interrupted
me.
Okay. I I was enjoying myself. I can't have 2 minutes of yapping
thing that I like cuz now you're not enjoying being here and
I don't like that. So I'm going to be better at that. Okay. I'm
I'm not joking. I It sounds like I'm joking. I've gotten this
criticism from some other people and I think it's actually like
a problem unironically. So, oh my god.
Listen, I'm trying to I'm trying to be a better person, man.
I can grow and be better. I'm I'm trying to grow and be better
for everybody.
And now I don't remember what I was Off topic. Are you willing
to accept donut to free? So, you were talking about chemistry
and then arithmalgia. You're tying it in with destiny, learning
about chemistry and
Somebody asked me why I know this chemistry stuff, but this isn't
really chemistry. It's just I I learned about gene mutations
cuz I had full genome sequencing done because ariththroalgia
can be caused by a gain of function u mutation in a specific
sodium canel uh sodium channel.
Um and that when that get messes up it's like the encoding to
the sodium channel the gain of function in it is like the excitability
within like um
so that's what causes like the burning pain that is the gain
in that function. So that's what that means when you're like
talking about gain of function mutations but I don't know if
he actually knows any of this stuff. It was just really interesting
for me to see that he was trying to learn about what this is.
I was like,
"Why? That's weird that he's listening to like 10 hours of
really random YouTube videos." But yeah, I don't know.
Nobody cares. I care and I will make you suffer. The more you
complain, the more I'll make you suffer. Just let me enjoy me
talking. I listened. I cared. We appreciate you. Shut up, Coan.
You left earlier. What did you even do? Did you go play Marvel
Rivals?
No, I was uh listening to other streams. I was playing rematch.
Yeah. Uh ruined. What's the moral drama? What's he done? He got
banned from my Discord and I think he's upset about it and I
I saw it was timed out. Somebody messaged me about it and I wasn't
sure what was going on, but apparently Yeah, it's
kind of annoying. He's been banned like three times in the last
week or two. Yeah, people might have had a hair trigger with
him this time. I keep trying to tell people though, like I try
not to get involved because
basically if I get involved then I have to like people will expect
me to like litigate this stuff, right? And it's like I don't
want to litigate Discord bans. It's a little different when somebody
comes on stream regularly for content though cuz then the Discord
ban actually disrupts my content. So personally in this case
Hey, so what do what do you think of this tweet? What do you
think of this What is it? Hold on.
No, like now I can't even show it. I just I thought it was so
funny and uh now I can't show it. God damn it. [__]
I totally disavowed that. Okay, I totally disavowed that. But
uh just reading it in the moment, it was very funny. Okay, I'll
show it on screen. Actually, that is funny. Unfortunately, unfortunately.
I totally disavow it. I laughed. Disavow. But I laughed. Hold
on. Hold on. Let me get it there. There we I can't see. What
am I looking at? Oh, my cam is hiding it. I can't see. I'm the
only one who can stop him forever.
What is this? I don't get it. You don't know who the show is.
Wait, so moral posted this?
Oh, is this unrelated? Okay,
I'm so confused. This is the Huthy kid that Hassan interviewed
that everyone said was anti-Semitic
and he's referencing Ethan Klein and saying, "I'm the only one
who can stop him forever."
Which is very offensive
doing some kind of laughing harm to Ethan Klein. I thought he
wasn't actually auth.
Wow. Okay. I'm going hit play on this
It's playing some emo music.
I didn't even do anything this time. What the What the Hello.
My name is Bernard. I'm an automatic moderation bot in the JTO
server. You were temporarily timed out for 14 days for the following
reason. death threats to another user. I didn't even [__]
do anything. I
the morale classic.
I like that his argument isn't I would never do this. It's I
didn't even do anything this time. I didn't even do it cuz I
believe I just got timed him out for something like this very
recently. I just got this randomly. I've been lying. What the
he threatened?
It was Riyle who did the apparently. Well, you unfortunately
have my uh It sucks cuz I don't want Riyle timed out either.
But unfortunately, yeah, if people are breaking the rules, they
got to go. If that's against the rules, and I assume it is, you
got to you got to step out for a little bit. Okay. If you're
doing real threats, if it's jokes,
you at first mod to see it judges it by how funny it is. Okay.
If it's funny enough, maybe, but probably not. What the I didn't
even do anything.
Is Mal unbanned now? Oh, wait. Don't tell me cuz it's going to
cut down. What the What? I didn't even do anything. What the
hell, dude? J. J. I've been alive. I didn't I didn't give or
death threats. What did I do?
I've been this whole time. What the
What is What did I even do? Is the messages still up in Discord?
I'm curious what they Yeah, we'll just analyze the messages.
Someone sent me the messages right now. We'll cover them on stream.
Is it because you put your stream in the media tab? I don't know
what that means. I didn't I didn't I didn't rape threat anyone.
I think what is going on?
You think I think was not know
that's that's the exact same
exact same cadence as the song saying
the biggest problem with was not that he was it that he not is
not that he invaded the oh he invaded Poland
or some it wasn't But then he goes but then at the end he goes
I think. Yeah. I think
what the was I that is what it is. I can't remember the exact
clip anymore. Man, I haven't hate watched this on in forever.
I haven't hate watched that guy in forever.
Like five minutes ago. Who did this?
I'm so confused.
This is so bizarre. This is so evil.
Oh, should we pull the Barbie person in? Is that what we need
to do? Does she mind being on stream? I'm going to pull her in
and then we'll see what happened. Hold on, Barbie. Can you explain
Okay, this is the stream, by the way. Don't say anything crazy.
Can you explain what happened? What just happened and Riyle
on your No, on your stream. Yeah, on the stream. So, if you don't
want to, you don't have to, but I would like you to. No, thank
you.
I'll pull the in. I'm trying to be more respectful. I'd normally
ban people who do that, right? But I'm trying to be I'm trying
to let the Discord grow on its own. Let it be what it's going
to be. Who would know, though? I don't know if would know. Somebody
tell me in gen chat right now if you can hop on stream and let
me know cuz I got
No, thank you. Hey, I I asked I asked
kind of was that. So, apparently
to rule with an iron fist. Um, no. I'm trying to let this stuff
grow up on its own because eventually they'll start paying me
for soundboards.
Wait, who am I pulling in?
I'm pulling
I'm just going to pull the in. Have you been following this?
You have any idea what's going on or you trying to figure it
out? Oh, this guy's just AFK. Oh, nobody doing anything today.
Oh, okay. Hold on.
Okay. Uhoh. Okay, I actually need to read so you guys can talk
for a second or I'll just hit play on the morale video and I'll
read this. Who is this guy? Uh, he's a streamer. Wait, did they
ban me for something Riyle said? Was he here when he got banned
or something? I Sorry, I'm trying to read. What's up,
Was he here when got banned or
I don't know. Yeah, I don't know. I'm trying to figure this out
cuz Dickers was in the channel. You're doing Okay, so they were
all on VC when it did it just happen. Is one of very few people
in that channel who are capable of explaining information? Yes.
And so I saw him and I was like, "Oh, maybe he knows what's going
on." So I pulled him into the What What do you want to know?
Do you know what happened with morale?
Um, apparently,
uh,
Riyle said something about,
um, was trying to explain to somebody that you don't need to
worry if moral says that he's going to kill you because he doesn't
know your address.
If people if people say that they're going to and you, don't
worry about it unless they know your address. Um, and then Royal
like cracked a joke about it and that like freaked somebody out
and so
yeah, morale got like banned, but apparently according to Royal
and Morau, it it it wasn't fault. Like he didn't do
That girl that you just dragged in said Morau has been threatening
me here for a few days. He was timed out and came back. He said
he'd slit my throat and me until I'm unrecognizable.
Weird.
I
I think he said that a few days ago. That was the first ban.
But then I think he came back to explain his uh to his explain
his race play.
Yeah, I did time out and then I said I was going to ret time
him out and I did not. I said I was going to give him a reprieve
and then ret time him out and I didn't do that.
Hold on. We have some breaking news, guys. Some incredibly important
breaking news. Hard not to hard to know how to take this. Okay.
Breaking news. Willie is spicy.
Willie is such a Willy stream. Willie has dropped his stream
idea. His show with Dan Saltman. Fighting with Dario who cooked
it was going to put him in an impossible spot. Why though? I
don't know why Dario got so butt hurt. No idea. He lost his mind.
Willie is so pathetic. It's crazy. We're just following Dorio
where wherever he goes.
Durio likes Dan Saltman. Willie likes Dan Saltman.
Dior doesn't
I don't. Yep.
So embarrassing. Grown man can't think for himself,
dude. Also, how weird is it that Dan is trying to pretend that
he thinks that Dioro freaked out over the disagreement? Dan's
the one who redacted his logs. No. Yeah. I Dan has been desperately
trying to find someone that agrees with him. He was here earlier.
I'm used to Dan redacting logs and like like literally anytime
there's a minor
Um
I don't I don't see that as like a reason I'd kick him out of
my server. That seems like an escalation. But like it's I if
that's what you do this fine. I think I just messaged somebody
deleted your loss. The going on. It's weird. If somebody redacts
all their logs with me, I'm assuming it's like complete bridge
burn. Really? I don't know. Yeah. Okay. like you don't you no
longer like trust me to like have this log. So cuz you think
I'm going to try and get back at you in some way. So it's like
we've clearly got no shed trust at all then. Okay. Whoops. I
don't know why you have shared trust with Dan in the first place.
You trust you trust Dan to act within his own interest. So that's
all you trust Dan with. Okay.
Well, Dan doesn't always redact DMs. Dan Dan has his DM set up
to autoredact with like some people, but mostly he doesn't redact
DMs until he like says something he shouldn't have. I had to
go I think they would have been totally fine to do a show together
except for the fact that or Willie and uh you know Dan would
have been totally fine to do a show together and Dan wouldn't
have freaked out except for the fact that Dioro last night said
Dan this is why I will never do a show with you. That's what
seemed to set Dan off. Before then it was relatively cordial.
Uh h
well it's that did that did set him off and then I think being
dismissed set him off as well. Like I think being being dismissed
was not cool being Dude Dario was so casual about it. Did you
did you watch that like the end of that where he's like uh yeah
I think um I'm done talking. I'm going to go on with my stream
now. Man, that conversation did not go well. And he like said
it to himself. He like stopped addressing Dan. He like said it
to himself. I was not a fan of that conversation or whatever
he said. And then Dan says something. He's
Dan says something back to him and he's "Yeah, I'm going to cover.
I'm going to cover, but I'm going to go now. Okay, I'm going
to let you go now." It's like, it was brutal. It was brutal.
Honestly,
I don't know. How does How does Willie get out of this with like
any respect
that he like made this decision?
Well, okay. Because Nick's going to do this. Nick's going to
go, "Oh, I don't know. I think I think Willie realized that damage
is a bit too unreliable, you know? I mean, we people gave Dan
maybe a little bit too much charity, but we all gave Dan too
much charity. So, I mean, it's fine. And and then we just move
on. That's why.
But yeah, in any just world, Willie would be treated like out.
He would be treated like the absolute he is. Uh constantly under
the thumb of someone else, whether it's Dan, Destiny, or Nick.
Just a total empty-headed low IQ Could they just be friends?
Stop making me defend the
do once already. Can they just be friends? They are friends and
they got each other's back. Is their professional business? That's
what I'm saying.
Yeah. Well, that's all that they're doing, isn't it? They're
just mates. They got each other's back. I don't think it's any
deeper than that, is it? No, but I was describing Will being
They're just mates. That's it. I don't think it's deeper than
that. Okay. That doesn't change anything I Um I mean, it kind
of changes the motivations. Yeah, cuz you're like
behind why I've done stuff.
I didn't say anything about Nick's Well, well, Willie being pathetic
or whatever it is you were saying. I don't Yeah, that's right.
Is it pathetic to do stuff cuz you feel like you're sticking
up for your friend? That's not why Willy's doing this. Well,
I you don't know what his motivations are and I don't either
cuz neither of us live. He's not sticking up for a friend. The
point that's being made here is that he cancels a show with Dan
for seemingly no reason simply because Dior was fighting with
him and
the only reason
puts him in a weird position as Dan said. That's not no reason,
is it? It might just feel weird. I think I would just want to
know what opinion that's so boring on that stream that is not
consistent with every past statement he's made,
right? Like I understand that the statements on doxing are new,
but the the strategy behind making those statements. Everything
about him, everything about how he approached this has been consistent
the whole time. Yeah, Nick's made the same statements as well,
like with the Denim's chat stuff. So yeah, I just don't know.
I don't know what changed. You know what's so obscene as well?
We watched on earlier. We saw Nick's reaction to that Denim's
chat stuff when it comes up in Idubbb's content deputy and Nick
it is does the most disgusting obvious shameful sweeping you
will ever see. It is like so. It's like a It's like a totally
different one than uh than his one on the stream. The stream
one was pretty bad where he just kind of goes like, "Ah, good
one. Good. Good
Yep. Was way worse. Way worse. And then when he then he watches
it the second time cuz he watches Ethan's reaction to it. He
just kind of like talks with his chat and responds to donos and
just completely ignores it. It's like, "Oh man, even Ethan's
taking the L here." But you defended it on the fact that no,
Ethan's actually describing it exactly the way that like I understand
it. It's like, well, no, Ethan's saying it's a cutout and it's
just been enlarged.
Yeah. Look, Jason, I'll send you a time stamp. It's here. What's
he going to say? He says it's time delayed, cut out, enlarged,
zoomed in. I don't know how any of that gets into edited and
filtered. Uh, hold on, hold on, hold on. Okay, I'll uh I'll litigate
the morale stuff, the moral and ri stuff after this.
Oh, okay. Um,
anyway, I will litigate all of this after. I'm We're gonna watch
this.
My friend got me chocolates for my birthday. I ate them. Based.
Okay. Here we go. Bring him on while he's doing this. Combines
them. It's one chat on one stream at different to make it seem
like someone is coordinating an attack on you. Love made a a
good point. You said, "Is someone is literally coordinating an
attack on him?" Absolutely.
every comment. I believe this is Wait, who that's that's a difficult
claim, isn't it? Who is coordinating the
That's a really, man, that is a really tough one. Of course,
I guess I guess you could say hypothetically someone is doing
it. Dude, how many how many times do I have to hear about the
deep state tonight? Have you Oh, I don't want to. You know, I
I realize I'm going to be like uh Nick with tipster and
but you go first, stickers.
Not supposedly. Okay. Not hypothetically. I think the word definitively
is used, right? Definitively. Somebody is conspiring against
him.
dude. Okay.
I have you heard Destiny use this term propaganda resonance model?
You guys heard? I don't think I have. I heard it for the first
time tonight and it's basically explaining how like Kiwi Farms
works with like his haters on YouTube like me or Queman to like
basically ruin his life, right? as literally he just invented
a word
for conspiratorial thinking. He's he's just using like this this
is like the swamp or the deep state. He's a conspiratorial resonance
model or sorry propaganda resonance model. And this is like the
same thing where people like people all engage in this exact
behavior, right? The exact behavior.
And then they they call out everyone else for doing it's like
bro you should just have a way to figure that out or just admit
that you're wrong. I don't know. Let's listen. Literally coordinating
an attack on him. Love made a a good point. You said, "Is someone
is literally coordinating an attack on him?" Absolutely.
Every comment I believe that's that's the same as definitive.
Yeah. Literally coordinating attack. Absolutely. Unequivocally.
Believe this is a live feed of the chat. This isn't edited. What
about the top right? I I thought these were
this I think when you full screen it. No, this is an edit. It's
a cutout of the full and then he plays the clip where Ethan explicitly
tells you. Okay. That they clipped the chat and it's like a cutout
of it. Chat. This just enlarged that really over the screen.
Yeah. They're different. I think what did Hold on. What did he
just say?
that they clipped the chat and it's like a cutout of it chat.
It's just enlarged over the screen. Yeah. He's saying they explicitly
tell you they cut the chat. Yeah. And it's not what they're saying
at all. Even saying they've just enlarged it and slowed it down.
It's not saying he's filtered it or anything like that. Yeah.
No, and it is clearly filtered. They're different, I think. Yeah.
And like it's it's it's directly explained to you in the stream
what exactly this is. Like love literally it's not timed the
same way. It's not timed the same way. Like all of the context
is in the clip.
This is kind of brutal, dude. We just rebuilt the Nick Bridge.
This is brutal. It's just This is totally sweeping. There's no
way to look at this other than just being plainly dishonest.
What? Stop. I just I literally just became friends with best
friends with Nick again and you guys are going to ruin it. God
damn it. God damn it. This The worst thing as well was Why does
it have to be a bridge? But it doesn't have to be a bridge burning.
Just
Why can't he not just admit, "Yeah, I've totally swept and been
dishonest to make Ethan look better. I can just stand on it cuz
that's really hard. We could probably just say that he was like
stretching his neck a little bit to try and make like a defense
of Ethan or thinking that Ethan was like smarter than he is.
Or get on the stream and just like address criticisms like what?
It's such behavior. Just act like this on stream all the time.
Refuse to engage with any criticism and then suddenly start acting
like oh this doxing thing's too far. No, you've been doing the
same for 6 months. Yeah. The worst thing as well was watching
or looking at the tweet that you pulled up when you had Ouggie
on stream as well when Nick's saying like, "Oh, anyone anyone
with half a brain, anyone with half a brain could have told in
well apparently Ethan has got it's got less than half a brain."
That was so rough. I wasuch trying to insult dog by pulling that
up. I swear to God. I was just like, "No, it's obvious that the
context here is people are going to look at the big thing on
the screen." Even with both of them there, it's just very obvious.
I mean, that's the clear intention, right? Otherwise, you wouldn't
have layered them like that to look like a pre-existing chat.
I And I don't know if we have this. I would just want to know
who actually made this clip. Do we know the providence of this
clip? Cuz I would love to know
or was it H3 Snark or sorry, not H3 Stark. Was it H3 Productions?
I don't know because I've seen the the clip posted on H3H3 Productions
before, the Denims one, right? I just want to know like the providence
of it. I want to know who directed it, who made it. I want to
know how this got put together
it would be really funny if it was coming from somewhere similar
to where the the whole Diddy party thing was coming from.
Lots of people, but it sounds like based on this clip, you knew
that it was and you just went with it anyway. It's not. Denims
has confirmed in her own video that those messages did come from
her chat and all of it is after
the Wait, I'm actually so
So, he's acknowledging that he he is acknowledging that he has
seen the Denims video. He knows what the Denim's video says and
he is choosing to relay exclusively. So, he's saying Ethan's
exactly right in what he's saying on the podcast, which he's
not. Ethan's lying. And he's also saying the only piece of information
that video is, oh those chats were actually from her chat. That's
not all Denim says though, is it? What Denim points out is that
that is filtered and has only 6% of the chat messages that occur
within the time frame that's shown at all. She like there's no
argument addressed here. It's just like blatantly dishonest.
You you're acknowledging here. You've seen the evidence. You
know how Ethan's lying here and you're choosing not to point
it
You're choosing to make a statement that is technically truthful
but actually totally avoids the real argument, right? Which is
basically
dismissed criticism. Yep. Like like when you say Hassan went
to a diddy party, but you know that he says he left and that
he was like weirded out and right you know all like the circumstances
or Hassan attended a brothel. It's the exact same thing. You're
saying like uh you're saying something that could arguably be
like okay Moody Morgan in chat if you don't see it you literally
don't understand what's going on. You literally do not understand
what's happening if you don't see it. It is as simple as this.
There is a chat log in this video that has 6% of the messages
from that time frame. So from the first message shown to the
final message shown, only 6% of the total chat messages that
were in the chat in that time frame are there. It is filtered
to include exclusively the CPS messages, kids messages, yard
messages. Those are the only messages that are shown. Ethan shows
this on his stream and he says, "Oh, this is just enlarged and
uh slowed. Look, it's just cut out of the corner. It's just enlarged
and slowed." Which is a total lie. It's filtered to exclude 95%
of the chat messages. Nick watches this. He knows this lie has
happened, but he says Ethan is totally correct. And then he says,
"Denims has confirmed that those chat messages came from her
chat in her video and does not present any of the rest of the
information that would show that Ethan is explicitly lying."
And he knows that. And Doro knows that. He's acknowledging he's
seen the evidence. So if you don't quote unquote see it, you
just don't get it. You're just not paying enough attention. You
don't understand what's happening.
Dude, I can't find I had the link to the Denim's response video.
I do not have the link currently. Hello. Who this? I vaguely
remember like well not vaguely I know what like
Destiny and Hassan beef is but why does Dan care this much? Like
did I miss I thought Dan and Assan used to be like Buzzy Maze,
right? Yeah. I'm just Was there something significant that happened?
Like why is Dan on this specific crusade now? I don't Is it just
cuz it's Twitch? Is it cuz he's bored? I don't Well, he normally
has like hobbies and stuff he does when he's just bored.
Dan said before about it being like feeling an injustice over
Steven being banned. Um I didn't find anything or if that's the
be all and end all but yeah
getting her son banned make it less of an injustice. He's just
doing a rust raid.
It's a midlife crisis. You just feel cool. Is it? That's okay.
I'm not here. Everyone's just talking over me.
Um, I just saw I I haven't seen anything since uh I watched like
half of Riyle's VOD that he uploaded uh from yesterday where
you guys were talking to Auggie. Um, so I'm not up on what's
going on now, but I saw you guys were just talking about Denim's
chat. Um, and how See, when I watched Ethan's Nuke video, like
I've been watching H3 the the podcast since it started pretty
much. And so when I watched that, I had a sense of good faith
with Ethan. And I had no idea how absolutely like chopped and
dishonest. It's disgusting. I would just like to state my disgust.
Um, okay. Goodbye.
Oh, that was quick.
Hello. And bye. It's uh it's pretty. Bye. Bye. Wow, so gross
when I hear it back to me. Me.
Okay, sorry. I'm back. What I was saying is that I don't understand
the thought process between
okay, if he gets Hassan banned, how does that make the injustice
of Destiny getting banned any different? Yeah, cuz it's not about
that at all. It's like that's kind of like a thin veneer of like
motivation where it's like, okay, I kind of don't like Twitch
for this. But the reason Dan's doing any of this is just because
he wants to feel like a cool epic internet leader who can send,
you know, internet people after someone and and cause things
to change. He wants to feel like he's got power, but nobody thinks
he's cool.
He's somehow managing to make an argument that even the people
that like him are not agreeing with.
It's like, I don't get it. who he's who is he trying to win over
here? I don't know. I feel like everyone in this space is pretty
against like the whole idea of report culture and getting people
banned over [__] right? So, I don't Why would you
want to then go on that crusade?
I don't get it. Hi, Kelly.
Hi. Sorry. Just wanted to say hi. It's me, your best friend.
I needed to I need I needed to briefly come in here. I'm about
to leave, but you guys are kind of uh you guys are enabling like
pure laziness right now. Dickers are supposed to release supposed
to release a Cameron F305 video like weeks ago and instead of
working on that in any meaningful capacity, uh he's sitting in
this VC contributing absolutely nothing. So, uh what do you have
to say about
I will say I will say I have no heat for until Shimu finishes
his next Tech video. Okay, Shimu, I know you're watching right
now. Get to work. I don't care if it's in review. Give it to
somebody else to review. That guy's too slow. Yeah, I knew you
were here. I knew he was here. Shimu releases quality.
Okay, so the wait is worth it. Releases mid. We shouldn't have
to wait this long for mid. Let get away with it. Let the world
know. Thanks. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Oh, I want to get
his reaction. I don't know if he heard. You think he knows? He
probably knows. She's probably spicy though about the podcast
being done. Oh yeah. Damn.
Okay. Do you guys think it's worth it to go back and explain
this whole thing? Like go back and show it with the original
Denims video. I can't remember. Somebody linked me the Denims
video last night. Might have been you. I can't remember. Um I
don't know. No, it wasn't you. It's just bl It's just blatant
Ethan just straight up lies about the nature of that clip and
Nick who saw it and it's blatant if you like. Yeah. Denim's contradiction
with the video. The reason she says they're lying or yeah, they're
lying is because she says there's a massive chat that's blown
up, it's filtered down to just these messages. It's like 6% of
the messages or something right from that chat. And when you
only show those 6% of the messages and say, "Look, everybody
in her chat was like clamoring to get CPS called," it gives the
wrong impression. It's like totally disingenuous for you to do
this, even if the chat's up there. And the way they're engaging
with that is saying like, oh, it's like really obvious that like
it's really obvious that oh that's not all of the chat. And not
only that, all of those messages were said in the chat. So it's
the same thing. It's not like those chat messages weren't sent,
right? Guys, I'm mad. What? I'm What am I doing? Right. I'm in
public. You mongaloid. What do you mean? Yes, Nicko sweeps Ethan
like crazy. He cries this guy. I will talk to Nick anytime about
this. He does not want to talk to me about it. He said as much.
Call him out on Twitter. Oh, do do a gay debate tweet right now.
Do a gay debate tweet otherwise you're hiding. The [__]
are you talking about, you mongalade? Have you heard anything
from Auggie about like getting a bait debate together or not?
No. He said last night he would be interested in setting it up
but said he thinks it's good. Would be good. I feel like after
Nick's debate with Augie a few months ago, there's just like
no interest after they debated on the Willy Matt video the first
time.
the Wait, I'm actually
Sorry about that. Um
I think they just they they see a lot of like they see enemies
everywhere, right? Like the whole thing with Chud doing the call
out like that was suddenly oh Chud's like trying to snake this
guy and take his audience
just seems like an unreasonable standard to have and it like
chills all possible criticism. So, and you just get like these
these big waves of people like you can't ever criticize people
going hyperbolic, like being way too hyperbolic, their takes
being like way over the line, and you constantly like chill any
of that like commentary coming back at you, then obviously you're
just going to go way off the rails into like three skulls were
sent for each of his children, you know, Nazi swords. It's going
to get way out way out to lunch. So, speaking of, I just got
food. What's up, Ellie?
I didn't realize it picked up my mud. Well,
well, what did you just leave? Guess so. Why don't people say
bye these days? Why are you guys so rude? God, you said something.
Just either no one listened or we didn't hear it. You didn't
say bye last time. I I did say bye last time, but you either
didn't listen or didn't hear it.
I doubt it.
I doubt it. You said night. Okay. Well, it wasn't night, was
it? You came back. No, I think you said night. I said I'm going
to bounce through it earlier. I why are you so quiet? I'm going
to need to turn you up. This guy just went live.
Wait, why is my chat up on the side? The hell? Do you guys see
this? That it's like Oh, this is like all your chats. They have
something with the site right now. Okay, I guess we're back to
the morale thing. I can't remember. We went over. We look at
the content deputy and then apparently the reaction to the content
deputy is also not good right from Ethan's reaction. Oh, right.
Yeah. He just like he just like pays attention to dinos and doesn't
address it at all. It's like barely worth
All right. I got you. All right. It's kick. What do you expect?
I mean, I expect some professionalism. God damn it. All right.
Are we moved? We're moved on from this. We can finally go back
to figuring out what happened with morale.
I think I'm just going to talk to people about this. We'll see
what's going on. And God is not around. Can I just bring in and
have him explain that?
Sure. Let me let me unttime out Moral for for stream content
right now. Like he's not going to give the most impartial
account, is he?
he's already been saying, "Oh, I don't think I said that." Actually,
well, yeah, his victim didn't want to testify, so that's their
own fault. Well, we just have the deleted messages, I assume.
Or was it on VC? Okay, gentle whale, thank you very much for
the 10 gift, dedicated. Another hour on the stream. Let's go.
He's already back. Oh, did I not I don't know how I just added
him without him actually hopping on stream. It's possible we'll
have a uh
a clip. Okay, a clip of our boy Quan doing his Willie impression.
Okay,
Masabo. Massano, you sure do read read well. Masso,
explain the tenant media scandal to me. Masso, I wonder did you
see him replying to that thread? uh like posting the fail docs
in Desty's community again. Did you see that? Quan like will
you guys shouldn't you told me earlier. This the second time
you told me about it though. Well, I'm sorry. It was going to
be I thought I was wondering if that had to do with part of his
uh what do you call it? Rationale for getting off the the podcast
with Dan. Just seeing who he was in bed with, you know. No, I
doubt it. I don't I don't know why Willy would ever I don't know
why it would ever give you a single idea that Willie gives about
doxing or anything like that after the last few months. Probably
care significantly more about it out in the open like that in
a community he's like openly. I don't think that had literally
anything to do with it. You can say that. I thought you would.
scumbag? You good? No, I think I think things hit people at different
rates. And when you see that
you see the the other doxing thing, I think those add up.
I don't think Willie is engaging in any kind of like critical
thought or realization. I think it is because Nick is saying
it's bad to hang around Dan now.
I think anything else is complete
Willie is not engaging like that. It's blatantly obvious. He
literally thought Destiny was like basic. He was like, I don't
give a quit in this Destiny stuff and I had to be corrected by
Nick initially like this guy's a total I don't know why you think
he's having a position on it. It's not. It's just what Nick says.
I just agree to disagree. Go ahead, M. Oh, there he is. So,
I did I did give a a death threat like a couple days ago. I said
cuz I said let I need to explain the whole story or else it seems
like I'm really crazy and I'm not. Okay.
So, I join the VC. There's like 40 people in. It's like a really
big VC. Everybody's muted except like five people though. Okay.
And this Barbie girl is like annoying and she she she starts
trying to talk to me and I say something along the lines of,
"Don't talk to me. You're annoying and I hate you." And then
she's like, "What the did I ever do to you?" And then like the
for 10 minutes straight basically. This girl is constantly trying
to ask me like, "Why do you hate me, Moral? What did I do to
you?" And I just keep telling her to shut the [__]
up and then eventually mute people, right? Yeah. I mean, you're
telling me I I'm well aware of that. Okay, I'm well aware of
that. You need to tell that to this broad, okay, that keeps complaining.
Why didn't you mute her? You wouldn't have been able to hear
her complain about you if you'd ever muted because it's way funnier
to cause conflict and and like All right. Well, let's just make
that I'll finish the story. Let's carry on. Yeah. Sure. Sure.
So, eventually it comes to the point where I'm I'm at my breaking
point. I say, "If you don't stop talking, I'm going to find your
IP." Okay. Which I can't do. I don't know how to do that. And
then she starts freaking out. And then I say I'm And then I do
I do this and then I say, "Do you hear what that is? If you don't
quiet down." And then uh she announces
her she announces her address in the VC and tells me to come
find her. Uh and I'm like, "Whoa, Jesus Christ." Um I did
Yeah. Yeah. She announced her address. She told me to come find
her. Uh, and then I I did threaten to her and stuff like that,
but she's been like making it seem way more extreme than it was.
I did threaten to her. I did. I to be clear, I did, but she's
been saying like he he threatened to my face until I'm unrecognizable.
I never did that. Okay. I I I did not go that far. I did threaten
to her at a base level. Uh, but she I think what she's doing
she's doing like a smear disinformationesque
campaign. She's like trying to say that I'm worse than I actually
am. Okay. is very evil and [__] and I I think um
I did apologize. I did I did say that I wasn't going to do any
more death threats when I got muted
Okay. And I've I have stood by that. She was being really annoying,
right? She was being
the time before or the sh time or how many times
the girl was I think she'll warranted Kelly. I can't say they
did anything wrong. You said you wouldn't. I did not say she'll
pull up the message. I have the message. Where is it in there,
too? There was in there. I didn't say I would rip anyone. I would
not say that. Hold
But I mean, I don't j pull this up to the evidence board, please.
Stop. I got to make you look less weird. I don't know. Is it
really hard for you to like control yourself so that you don't
say these types of things? Um, says, "I think she just wants
to be left alone, but good luck." And Ralph responds, "Yeah,
I want you doxed and but you don't hear me flapping my lips about
it." That feels like exactly what I just said. Well, no, he didn't
say he was going.
Yeah. No, he said he once heard docs.
He wouldn't necessarily I don't know what difference that makes.
You just want it. I'm not going to be doing
you or anyone else. You don't mind who does it, but you want
it to be done. I'm sorry that doesn't make it look less demented.
It's threat. Well, to be fair, I think it would look significantly
worse if I was going around
threatening to women. I'm not like that. I think women are beautiful
and I think we should listen and learn and
who clearly had like a holdover, right? Clearly, what if she
was in my Discord and she read that message and she was like,
"Yes, I I read you loud and clear." Okay. Yes, Mr. Moral. Yes,
Mr. Moral. I hear you loud and clear. Do you think my my my ethnic
my ethnic companion would have doxed
this this
sort of snow monkey is what you're saying? seems like a Okay.
Well, I I was not intending to threat Listen publicly. I apologize.
Okay. I apologize that you got so upset at what I said. I was
not trying to threat you, threaten you, okay? That's not the
case at all. And to this to this Barbie person, uh I do think
this Barbie person is incredibly subhuman, and I I think they
should come on stream and litigate this. and the fact that they're
running repeatedly uh while also being a former Wick mod and
a current Malcolm mod, you know, I think it's I think it's like
appropriate to take this person who says they're like afraid
of you and start saying where people can find them. That's like
an appropriate response right now, dude. It's pretty unhinged.
They're a public figure.
I don't care. Does that kind of behavior being a
Like how like what they're all public
I'm not doing anything. Well, I think Kelly, if you were a Wick
mod, I think you would have a very different, I guess, phenotype,
if you get what I mean. How? Okay. Well, your her phenotype is
not why you're disgree. Kelly, do you disagree?
I think you're full of I rest my case. I rest my case.
I don't know why you so weird last week, but can you not just
be normal? I don't believe I said I would slit her throat. I
I think I think it was exclusively the gun.
I do know for a fact that I did not say I would kill her or I
would shoot her in the head until she's unrecognizable. I do
know for a fact I did not say that. Uh the slitting of the throat
I'm less
uh concrete on. I guess that plausible, but I don't. So you said
it. I don't believe I did, but I don't even if you did just own
it like be like, "Yeah, I I threatened to take the lives of my
enemies online."
Well, I did with a gun. I don't think I did it with a knife is
what I'm Is it true that you're holding out evidence on us and
you have screenshots and clips from voice chats?
Why is this Barbie person claiming you have that then? Uh I got
sent screenshot. Oh, hold on. Let me look at my message requests.
Uh
no, I don't think so.
Was he sent to somebody else? They might be sitting in my mod
chat and I'm just
The top answer is I wasn't. Did Zoe not intend to join the VC?
Yeah, that Zoe was joining the VC. Why is that an option? Is
Zoe pro pro or anti morarale? Which which side is Zoe on? Uh,
anti morarow over the shell bunner comments. Shockingly,
See if I've got apparently I have voice calls here. Let me see.
Listen, I did do a death run. I just don't I don't want to be
uh you know, listen, I
I think this Barbie person there's some there's some avenue of
peace we could find and they're not they're not going down that
road. I guess it seems like this person is the problem, not you,
moral. Yeah, it's not like morale's been drained for three other
people in the last week. I mean, we've basically just me this
whole time. Has to be the women who are at fault.
It can't be morale.
Ellie, I just don't understand why you have this like this like
vendetta. Probably because Shell Burner said absolutely nothing
crazy and then you responded with that out of her way. Yeah,
I don't believe you. I think you're full of
Yeah, you got to think about it. Jerry, what about No, sorry.
Kelly.
Good one.
That's the yellow woman. Cute.
Would it help if I said I was in Iceland right now and it would
be impossible for me to kill anybody
from America here? I mean, I don't think anyone thinks you're
capable of anyone. It's not really the point, is it? Thank god.
Okay.
I just feel like dead air right now really serves to like focus
in on Queen's latest comment. So, I'm just going to let it hang
for a little bit. I said, "I am the other woman." It was a They've
got similar syllables. It's easy to do. I've just got a dono
that says, "Kelly blows dogs for quarters." I don't know if this
is
I don't know if that's something I should, you know, bring up,
unfunny. I don't know. People give you money. That's unf. Kelly
owns you. You really block broke this Aiden guy. Jesus. So, I
I'm just I'm reading this chat and I I can't help but feel as
though this I see a message from Maximus, who I am I am best
friends with in private, so I don't know why he's saying this.
He says they're both fake. He said something unhinged enough
it matches the
I just said I would kill her with a gun. I think I think adding
on to the um
I think adding on to the uh like the unrecognizable adds like
a level that's well you got to consider the context as
Just shoot her not until she's unrecognizable. Just shoot her
a bit. I just pop her once in the head. I don't understand like
why would I go overboard? I guess why would I go overboard as
the message saying I want you do
on the screen. Well, I understood my my shortcomings
repeated that behavior. I mean that that is out of context to
be fair. No, it's not. The context makes it worse because it's
a normal conversation and then you just lose.
No, the context is that it's shell. Anything against
but damn. No, we don't have shell burner exception here. There
is no exception. She's really annoying.
I I guess I guess ultimately Kelly I guess like what criticisms
or I guess advice do you have? Like how do I Sorry. Before you
respond to that, Kelly, I have to let know that I just got a
donation. should be
that I can set my price to keep morale banned from the community.
I kind of want to test how high that price could go.
Who who said this? Some some random donator just said like set
a price and ah how much how much to keep morale out of the community.
So I just I don't know who that is. So I'm kind of hesitating,
you know. Listen,
if you get a ton of money for banning me, I'm not going to be
Listen, it is what it is. Okay. Uh, I wouldn't actually ban you
like long term. Hold on.
Time out. Zoe. I don't know how long Zoe was timed out for, but
she needs to go
So, Zoe person that Paragon sent to
Which now makes it really weird that I just timed her out. So,
wait, why did Zoe get timed out? Sweeping for Paragon. Interesting.
oh, and on time out. Okay, I can't explain it. She came back
and said moralism.
People are sending me screenshots from your Discord to litigate
now, Kelly. So, I hope you're happy. Apparently, this poor random
fellow, someone said that uh he should be and you just didn't
care about it. I know you don't actually care. You just said,
"Oh, I know it doesn't work." If this is anything to do with
locker, I do not care.
They would constantly sit in there and wind up locker and it
was just very boring. I said I wouldn't deal with any of it cuz
can just be as annoying as she wants
then like sure
remember when Yog threatened to rap dog I lock her has been my
discord for months either we time that guy out time that guy
out yeah free that guy free that guy free that guy April hell
it's July
yeah the exceptions are men saying they want women is worse.
Don't fight me on that. Deal with it. I uh I think now being
timed out for like a reasonable amount of time is probably okay
because
Well, what did I even do? What do you mean? What do you mean?
Uh I let you out early and you should have been let out early.
You do need to sit out. You need to stop doing like these stupid
edgy comments to random women in my Listen, I What if I've I've
I've significantly toned down and what if I I I apologize. And
what if I promise to
I think you're like say I don't think any of these are a big
deal really. Are they? Uh this one's pretty bad.
You can't do this one. The the sh Oh, I don't know if it's
in contact.
Nope. Nope. That was like a month ago. I I've I've served my
time, whatever it may be for that one. I got timed out for like
two days for that already and I served that. It's fine. You weren't
You didn't serve out all your time. I timed you so you could
come and talk about your weird No, not for the for the sh the
shell burner one was a while ago. That was months ago. Oh, right,
right, right, right. There's month probably.
Uh, the Barbie one was like 3 days ago or something.
So, why did you get timed out today? I Well, that was because
someone said that I said something that Riyle actually said and
I got in trouble for it when it I didn't do anything. I see the
irony here is that Moral, sorry, Riyle literally just DM' me
30 seconds ago. Moral isn't routing me out and I'm not going
on without Moro. I don't know. Is he behind on the VOD?
Did I say what did he say? Is that ratting? Okay. Well, okay.
Well, I I'll say what he said. He said, um,
Kelly is defending because cheating on her husband with Kelly.
They're Okay. Well, I don't know if that's true, but regardless,
I I You don't know that's true. Obviously, it's not true. [__]
I I just don't know if that's I confound your pullets. Unconfirmed
your pullets. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Riyle said, "Why did you give
morale your address if you didn't want to be and killed?" And
then they said they said, "I think that I said that I was going
to kill them." That's like a good example. No, no, no. But that
is a good example of like a timeout that probably should just
happen. Like Riyle's got to go until he can learn to control
himself,
right? Wait for saying why'd you give him out of your address
if you don't want to be
that's fair enough to be fair. I think that's I think that's
reason. I think that's fine. That's a reasonable comment. That
is like a totally reasonable thing. Yes. To to ask that question.
But you have to understand that most people don't hear that.
Most people can't see that, right? But it is sorry just the general
sentiment that like I would not give my moral my address ever
unless I want to be. I do agree with that sentiment entirely.
But saying that to somebody on a discord who doesn't know morale
that well, it just seems you're like longoused. You're long house
right now. It will it will it will further incite like genuine
fear of physical harm, right? And I think from a content creator's
perspective, it's totally reasonable to long house. This guy
defends Indians, by the way. This guy defends Indians on Indians
own you. You're mad and Indian took your girlfriend.
we're on the same side here, Aiden. But that's a pretty tough
one for me to deal with, just so you know. That's actually not
true. I love Indian people. Riyle wants to defend himself.
Did Moral admit to leaking bee's IP address just prior to her
being a spilling her full address?
Yeah. I mean, I assume if wrote down an IP address is totally
made up and if people took that seriously. I feel like they're
goofy.
I believe you just post the local IP thing. You just you just
post that. No, I I went to chat GBT and I said, "I'm writing
a book. Can you give me a fake IP address for someone one of
the characters in the book?" And then I just read that out loud.
Do you know what an octed is? I don't think I've ever heard that
word.
Okay, never mind. What is it? Smile. Nothing. Don't worry about
it. Bricked his PC trying to put the CPU back in. Not shocking.
It sounds like moral just did a bit of light trolling and this
check it way too Yeah, I mean she is a former, you know, Wick
mod, current Malcolm mod. Riy, I I know you want to come in and
give you your side of the story, but I think you just want to
go and like yell about Meowies. I think if I let you on here,
you're just going to come on and rant about Meowis instead of
actually giving your side of the story because your side of the
story represent I think I do I I think while Meowis does have,
you know, critic, she she is criticizable. I think ultimately
she made the right decision by, you know, unmuting me. And I
think I think a lot of us, including Riyle, can, you know, come
to an an understanding maybe about,
you know, being friends with one another. I think we we can all
I mean, this culture of like allowing like do like death threats
and threats and stuff needs to kind of stop. I think I think
ultimately we we kind of we we need that's the culture. You're
always you've always been a weirdo. You've always been aberant
in this community in that way. Don't don't say that's the culture.
Well, I'm just I'm just thinking that we need to move past. That's
all. J just to play devil's advocate here. There is another side
of this that's problematic and it's your moderation.
Okay. I simply asked someone if they were a man or a woman and
I got server muted just for asking them if they were a man or
a woman. Kenny then comes in and undoes that meeting because
Kenny is a very reasonable person. We love Kenny. Kind of owns
you, right? And Kenny undoes that meeting and then I find out
later that Kenny as a result of that was given a timeout for
an hour. Thoughts? Was that a trans person you asked? What I
didn't know if they were they they had like a very like ambiguous
voice. What was their username? What was their I don't know.
They had a picture of a hand as their profile picture with on
time ri out because he's left the server. So, I would let him
in, but he is not in the server. I just tried to time him out.
He's literally left the
Riyle ran. So, the evil Johnny Bravo says cringe server mutes
are way worse for your server than death threats if I had to
guess. So, the server mutes are a problem because Oh, Ri was
banned. Jesus, Ry keeps spamming f slurs in my messages. No,
no. Ryle didn't leave. Ry was banned. I just maligned Riyle's
name. Give me a second. Is this a picture of Aiden? What the
I know. Do not pull it up if it is what I think you got sent.
Is that real?
Is what? What is what real? I If it's the one I think you got
sent. No. It is real. It is real. I don't know what he's talking
about. I know what he's talking about. And it is real. It's the
one where he looks all spotty and that's real.
Mau Shel lives in a trailer and drunk out of her mind every day.
She her cousin and her mom is a schizophrenic abusive crack.
I don't know if that's
Hold on. I'm trying to figure out, dude. Why can't anybody in
this Discord just be normal?
I think and uh Ri hand themselves pretty well.
Like I said, moral, you give off chill vibes like you lowkey
like kids, but you went to therapy and got impulse control and
you would never hurt one, if you know what I mean. Happy when
I see your streams. Smile. Don't know if that's true. I'm not
I'm not weighed in with my opinion on this and people are like
getting mad at me. Okay, dude. Wait, wait, wait. I I just realized
so we were talking about the Willie thing a minute ago. So eight
hours ago, Leroy something puts out a tweet saying, "Hi, Willy
Mack show. What are your thoughts on current Nick and Dan discourse?
I'd love to hear what you have to say." 3 hours ago, Willy Mack
replies to that. Tune in tomorrow, lol. So up until literally
like 3 hours before it was cancelled, even 2 hours before it
was cancelled, Willie was on board with this. Very quick change
of his mind there. Very rapid.
Anonymous just tipped $5. I actually like Maru and Riyle, but
here's some more money to fund their re-education. Okay. Wait,
what? Hey, Riyle should be able to join. I don't see him in the
waiting room. I'm waiting. I don't know if he's joining. Maybe
he's not joining. Okay. Also, can you link the Willy Mack tweet
or are they deleted? Oh, I can grab it. Hold on. Barbie is saying,
"I'm certain this will go well and it won't result in Ralph following
me to three different VCs." She said before she left the VC,
"You're welcome to follow me if you want." And then I followed
her. She gave me permission. In fact, she invited me to do it.
So confused. So true. So vied. Like I don't Why was she If she's
m If she didn't want me to follow her, she didn't have to say
that. I don't understand. I'm sorry. Hold on. What? Hi, Willie
Mac Show. What are your thoughts on the current Nick and Dan
discourse? I would love to hear what you have to say,
but tune in tomorrow. Wow. Three. Willy's gonna be taking a strong
anti-Dan position tomorrow. That's what my sources have confirmed.
Do you do you guys think that uh do you think Willie actually
canceled or did Dan just go like hey I know like this is who
I have to ask but can Willie still come out to play tomorrow
and Nick was just like no no he can't
is do you think Willie even knows that it's canceled yet? Wait,
you think Nick and Dan are still in contact?
I was I was definitely discussing a totally real thing that probably
I know you're speculating. Like I I'm not even speculating. I
do not think that Dan actually went to Nicholas Dorio and said,
"Hey, can Willie still come on my show?" And then Willie and
then Nick said, "No, he can't anymore." And then Willie was never
consulted. I don't actually think that happened. Literally. No.
Okay. You would be You would be the type to believe something.
So, just wanted to double check. All right. All right. They do
the show tomorrow. It's going to be insane. Oh, please. Wait.
Was
I imagine if they they do the show tomorrow is scheduled, it's
going to be insane. So that's what that's 4 hours ago. So an
hour after this tweet is when he says, "Tune in tomorrow." Right.
Damn. Cancelled the day before.
It was canceled the day before.
Well, can we talk about how Nick went after Dan harder than Queman
ever could? Like that's crazy. Like that that Queman swept for
Dan harder than Dior. You know why, right?
Why?
Because if you just constantly tell Dan, "Dan, you're crashing
out. Dan, this is not good. Dan, you're not Dan, you're not making
a good argument right now. You're just telling that like softly,
then you don't have to like scream at him or have like a meltdown.
You just eventually use nose. You're just like you are just filtering
yourself. You're just announcing that you don't you just can't
see how everything's working. You're filtering yourself hard
right now."
Who you talking to? What? What? Aiden can't see the mechanic
to play. Aiden can't see the way things are moving. Aiden's like,
"Oh, you're not going after Dan, but Dan's so evil." It's like,
"Yeah, cuz you're dumb." Do you have some secret plans in the
works or something? Like, you've had this discussion before.
I Is Kelly not going to respond to all this talked about her?
Is that true? I have no clue. Uh, we you
No, I I am actually a Kelly fan. It does not seem like it's reciprocated,
but I am a Kelly fan. You make me laugh a lot.
I think uh I think Nick's dropping a video on dad. How did this
all go so wrong so quickly?
It's almost like there were people in the background consistently
pushing for this to happen.
I would never, you know, I'd never assume that or think that,
but this just happened so quickly. It's crazy. Okay,
I've received a DM DMs from Salvo Pancakes on Twitter. He's saying
to me, "What's your deal, kid? Better keep Dior's name out your
mouth. Take this as your only warning. Why is he going to eat
him? I love by the end of this month, Dan and Ethan will break
up. No, I don't think so.
Although, I wonder how Ethan will take this. Wait, isn't that
going to be fantastic content? Isn't Ethan back tomorrow? Doesn't
Ethan have to come back tomorrow and discuss this? Wait, am I
crazy or is that true?
Can anyone anyone here remember
what? Sorry, Ethan's back tomorrow, right? H3 podcast back tomorrow.
Like he literally has to comment on this. His like two biggest
No, he's not he's not discussing any drama, right?
bro? No drama. Posted on Insta that he won't talk about any drama
tomorrow. Wonder why. I do wonder why.
Okay, I think I unttimed out Riyle. I think he wants to give
his side of the story. We can kind of float back into this if
he's going to join. What did Royal say? I have no clue.
What did Sorry, what did Royal say that was attributed to you
moral since you seem to know it was the why did you give moral
your address want to be Yeah, I already said that. Yeah.
Oh, okay. Is that it? Is
Yeah. Yeah. I was muted for the death threat when I didn't do
it. Juck, just make like a text channel in your server that allows
for that kind of
Yeah, that's actually the solution I was going to give to other
people as well was just we're just going to have a channel spicy
chat. It's going to be a spicy chat basically.
Dude, nobody uses spicy chat anymore. Everyone moved to Icy Chat
like weeks I don't I've never even heard of it. So,
that's hard to believe. Can the Can your Can your spicy chat
be called like Maui chat or something? I'll consider it. You
think it would be funny if Dan can't streams circumcision was
botched and instead his name was Dan can't cream. I'll see everything
I said about Shell is true. Kelly knows it too because Shel tells
her all her little secrets a tiny bit. Shelp husband is depressed
and because of her. Where are you reading this from? I don't
see these messages in the chat. Are you just like making fanfiction
on the side? No, it's my I'm streaming as well. Sorry. Yeah.
Oh, apparently Riy is not joining now. So bizarre. We've reached
the time of the night where it's just like absolute nonsense
VC chatting.
I'm going to go to bed.
Good night. Okay. Have a good night, Kelly. Bye. Good night.
See you. Bye. Okay. Let me see this Oct tweet. Let's see here.
Oh, hold on. Oh,
dude. Nick's like everywhere on Twitter when he when when Nick
is upset with people. He just he's like my spicy screenshot.
Oh, he's my spicy screenshot. I own this. I own you. I own this
loser.
Okay. Uh I mean, yeah, probably. But it's fine. Looking for an
editor now.
I probably not. I don't know. I Dude, I don't know. People get
angry because there's like eight different people messaging me
and then I'm trying to run the stream. I have to run the stream,
too. I need somebody else they can like send to who's not like
figuring out what's on stream and watching this as well. It's
actually not a hard job. I actually do not struggle to do it
at all. I'm just lazy. But move Kelly's thing. Oh,
as I as I don't monitor what's on stream and I leave this up
for 10 minutes.
GG. God, I need to find a better I need to like actually write
custom CSS for Discord reactive or something cuz it's actually
it's too annoying. We've actually Dan Saltman podcast scheduled
for tomorrow is now cancelled. Saltman claims Nicholas Dioro
is the reason why fighting with the cooked was going to put him
in an impossible spot. Translation: He doesn't agree with Dan.
Still got me blocked. Just unblock, bro. You don't have to follow
me. Just unblock. Quote tweet this mouse. See, Kelly ran. Okay.
Well, I mean, it is uh shocking that after I read that last message
you sent, she did leave the VC. So, I'm going to put a pin in
that, I guess. O go on and debate, Dan. If you disagree with
them, you cooked us on. You got a decent shot to put up a good
Willie Mack versus Dan Saltman.
Debate on doxing. I guess let's go. Listen,
I don't want that. Okay, cuz if there's if there's one person
Dan could probably like debate, it's almost certainly Willie.
Okay,
interesting. Where where were we? What were we doing? We're watching
moral stream and then
the boy Mindset Dean hour 37. I got a lot of stuff left to go
tonight. So, we're going to have to make more content. Well,
I guess uh final words. I I won't I won't threaten women anymore.
I'll be nice. Um and I think uh I think going forward, we'll
just be kind and no more no more no more threats, I guess. Right,
I just I you know, you clearly don't have the the
socialization required to use the word in most conversation.
I would just consider dropping it from your vocab off stream
entirely. Well, I mean, sure. I mean, yeah. I mean, I I guess
I guess ultimately Well, I Well, I didn't say that was Riyle
Uh, no, the shell thing. Oh, okay. That's the game, I guess.
Yeah, I'll just be kind going forward. I think I think that solves
everything pretty much. We don't have to be kind. Also, maybe
we'll make some kind of spicy chat variant that will be more
of it be the antisocial area. Shimu, you were in the waiting
room. I have no idea what you're coming on to say, but I obviously
am struggling to make content right now, so basically anything.
Yeah, I was just going to say like how insane. Um, it's just
crazy that Dan is trying to push this doc thing. It's actually
so awesome because it's like the dumbest. He has absolutely nothing.
It's just a YouTube channel and like anybody
nobody I I mean it's crazy they even tried to push it in the
first place. And I guess like some people buy it cuz I mean it
got a lot of traction I guess like most of his attacks on Assan
get but there's really nothing there though. It's crazy to me
that he like blew up this whole thing for that one little narrative,
you know?
Uh, but I So, I don't know that he really blew it up. I don't
know that he acted out of line with what he's been doing for
the p I think he acted almost entirely in line with what he's
been saying for the past
how the long
probably six months,
right?
Yeah. But this one's like really bad. Like there's other ones
that like you have to get some kind of context for like the denims
one that uh Queman brought up the other night. I actually didn't
even know about that either. I didn't realize that they like
filtered the chat. That one's really bad, but it takes like an
extra step. Yeah, I didn't know about that. It takes like an
extra step, you know? There's probably like 5 minutes or something
where you have to explain it. The docs one is like it's literally
like a YouTube channel name, you know? Like just on the face
of it, it's completely
So like it's just crazy he tried to sell
Yeah, sure. I would say the like the other smears you've been
pushing against Assassan have been totally welcomed and will
still be totally welcomed by everybody who thinks this is really
bad,
right? Like nobody's actually against this because it's absurd.
They're they're like against it because probably because it looks
like way more insanely hypocritical given the uh what do you
call it? The like just like of how it would affect them essentially.
But like the in terms of just like lying openly, like there's
tons of lying openly that'll still be endorsed. Like do you think
anybody's gonna stop doing the Hassan brothel thing or the Hassan
Diddy Party thing? I think that's still going to be like totally
all over the place. Yeah, I guess so. I mean, the Diddy Party
thing I almost feel like
people almost meme it or something, right? It's not like a Is
it like I mean, do people treat it like a serious allegation?
I feel like they're just kind of like throwing at the wall with
the Duty party thing. I like just remember we're in like I realize
that we're all right. There's like a ton of around us, but this
is still like probably like the 99th percentile of drama community
intelligence or something, right? Like it's like like realistically
the people on Twitter who are like propagating these things and
getting other people to believe them are all like robots.
Yeah, I guess that's true. Like like h
everyone else's Smaggle. Get out of here. No, Smaggles. Smanggles
been like on point through this whole thing as far as I can tell.
Most of Smanggles tweets through like a lot of the Ethan Klein
stuff have been Yeah, they've been good. Um,
but it's just Dan is to me is just like an Alog, you know, like
just through and through. Like he'll push false narratives or
he'll like twist things, you know, just to like, you know, his
enemy or whatever. like truth really isn't or like you know the
total truth isn't really uh important to him. It's all about
just like you know with someone that is important to him a lot
of the Jesus. Sorry I got a bunch of going on as well my DMs.
Um
I do think you have a good point. I'm sorry I missed what you
just said and I probably have to ask you again. And but I do
think uh the point is probably good though that you're like that
given it's like
uh whatever something crypto YT like that that does just sort
of make it like obviously laughable on its face to most people.
You add in the fact that like the guy's picture which is like
the only piece of PII you could argue has unexposed is in his
Twitch profile. Like it's just there's literally nothing there.
So it is just very much like so much easier to to convince people
of this. I think I had to think about Danly
to side with Dan on it. You literally have to like get on your
knees and admit you're his like to go along with the narrative
he's trying to push. Like that's how bad it is on the face of
it. So it makes sense that people don't want to, you know, push
that one. But it is crazy that Dan even tried to do it in the
first place. Like he's he's nuts. I think he had a different
narrative this morning that worked better which was like well
you know I don't really think it's that bad but like it's against
the 2s and you could argue it's against the law right like he
was basically like well I don't really care but you know you
could argue and it's like well then what are you doing why are
you arguing that's not even true either because it's not confidential
right the guy's yeah I don't think it's yeah the guy's username
it's not cuz he's offering his username right so in no way is
it confidential so it doesn't break any to that narative The
profile the profile is not confidential. You could argue his
picture is confidential, right? You could argue that. Um, no,
because the you can't be profile picture and it's I mean, well,
his profile picture on Twitch is his face. Okay. Yeah. And his
YouTube channel, he's on camera, right? So, I that wouldn't make
a difference, right? I mean, it wouldn't matter either way because
it's a username. As I understand it, Hassan just put the username
into YouTube or whatever and it came up, right? It's under the
same name. Yes. Well, he put in the wrong one first, but yes.
And that's more that's another thing D was going for was like
the guy who didn't who he didn't actually want to talk to. Uh
that is um sorry, the guy who he didn't want to actually insult
is probably the guy who got quote unquote doxed here, right?
If you wanted to argue that, but then it's it's like dude, then
I don't even know how you argue intent in that case. It's goofy.
Yeah. It's a public facing social media profile, you know, and
yeah, it's just Yeah, I
like I'm like basically trying to give the steel manat of what
Dan's arguments are. I don't really agree with them either, but
at least it was better today than it would last night. Well,
he was more detailed, I guess. Like he listed all this stuff.
I don't know. I guess he's just using chat GPT. He brought that
up a few times. People use that all the time now. I I don't use
it very often, but I guess people use it all the time. It seemed
like he just did that and then had all these, you know, different
things just making chat GPT prompts and then listing that for
sources for this law and that law and all this stuff. Yeah. Well,
it's more in like how you filter the questions down, right? You
filter the questions down so that you get like the responses
you want, but you as you include more information or like withhold
certain information, you filter it down so it's like pretty obviously
the case. We added like a few more questions in and once it was
like, "Oh, these are public profiles. Oh, he like has his picture
in his profile. Oh, it's like it literally says like, "Oh, these
need to be confidential pieces or like like hidden pieces. If
you expose them publicly yourself, then they can't be considered
PII, right? If you just announce to the world, this is me, then
it's not PII, right? Like if I signed up to Twitch with my full
address as my username, I couldn't go, whoa, you just used my
full address. What the?"
Right. So, yeah.
So, the question we've all been waiting for is coming now. Where's
the TechTome video? What? How is the review passed? Are we How
long does it take to review the video? Yeah, I've been like uh
poking at him or whatever, but yeah, it'll be it should be out
this week. I don't want to say like it'll be out this week. It's
It's pretty much done. I'm like just He's just doing that final
bit of audio editing to make sure that it sounds worse than it
does on Discord.
Jeez, bro. I think uh I think people like freak the out my Discord
tonight. I have to see here.
I was just looking.
I guess I guess membership is up. People get like so mad about
stuff. It's so weird. Did nothing wrong.
No, Mal is uh Mal is a little Mal's a little crazy. He's just
got to control himself a little bit. I don't need to totally
control himself. He just control himself a little bit. Chief
pulling out a classic with pork. You get see that getting posted
a whole
The more Kelly complains about the content quality, the more
your views have gone up. Canary in the coal mine. Wait, are views
going up right now? There's no way. It's not possible, bro. What?
How? Okay, cool.
Yeah, you need you just need to be well socialized to know when
you can talk about rape. Okay, now infamously, I am probably
not the guy to really even make the judgment on this. So, but
I understand it at least. I don't really get mad when people
tell me, "No, no, no, you missed your timing here." All If morale
was joking, what's the big deal? You know, I don't know. That's
how I would look at it. Um, yeah, but the thing is is like people
feel uncomfortable even if uh people are just joking, right?
Like if you're if you're doing like casual like joking racism
around people a whole bunch, they can feel uncomfortable and
you could be totally sincere and like joking the whole time,
right? Like just not but it can still make people Yeah, but who
I mean that's the thing with jokes, right? Who cares if someone's
uncomfortable? But um yeah, but if it's making like a lot of
people feel uncomfortable and leave, there's like there's just
a standard decorum that people want. I basically just told my
mods is like, "Yeah, if you think somebody's being like super
weird, just time them out." Yeah, it's different for how you
want to run like a server or something, right? Like you might
have rules, but just in general, I would say like, "Who cares?
Someone's joking, you know, and someone gets their feelings hurt
or whatever."
Yeah. Mal gets special treatment because he is uh he comes on
stream. That's how it is. You were gonna say because he had that
girl, right? The n word. For some reason, at Jto, if Hassan supports
doxing too, what's the harm in engaging in team sports with the
Dan method?
Uh, where does Hassan endorse doxing would be my first question.
Um, and then no, it it doesn't. Like, I don't endorse doxing
people who have like tried to dox me. I'm not going to go out
and like try to lead a campaign to get that done. Bad empanada.
Hassan said I endorse bad empanada doxing people. Really?
You can't hold people guilty for like what other people do. At least
I I don't typically. As someone just has a specific he has that
whole thing of just like he's not going to sit there and fight
with you over your methods if you're directionally in the same
side as him, right? That that's like his whole thing. He says
that oh this guy's crazy and I don't agree with everything he
does. But he's not going to sit there and go wow bad such a bad
guy because he doxes people he thinks are genocide supporters.
He's not going to focus on that because he's, you know, got his
political narrative that he wants to maintain.
It's kind of crazy if you think like the same as a whole bunch
of people around like the DG community too. They have that exact
same position. So like that's Josiah's position infamously like
I'm never going to go fight with somebody who's in my camp because
it's just a waste of time. I'll go fight. a very common political
position. It's incredibly common position for people that are
very politically motivated is do not attack people that direction
on the same side as you because it's a waste of time and only
emboldens the other side. Yeah. Sorry I cut you off, Shimu. Oh,
it's all good. I was just gonna say um if people
if Hassan was like suing people and doing all the doxing and
threatening to sue all these like H3 fans, I mean they would
be losing their mind. That's kind of the weird thing about this
whole conflict is like I feel like it's very I guess you have
bad empanada and all these people doing all this, right? But
at least in Hassan's case, like it feels kind of one-sided, you
know? It's like taken up to like 11 with the lawsuits and stuff
and it feels
one-sided to me, I guess. I don't know. But I don't I don't really
attribute like everything those like snark reddits do to like
these streamers, you know? To me, that's just like a platform
where like the nons get on or whatever and say, but I don't know.
I feel like if it was the shoe was on the other foot, people
would be like losing their mind over it. Did you see that the
um the Houthy guy or the the alleged Houthy kid was like making
threats? Dan tweeted it out, but I'm guessing that they'll talk
about that. He was like, "I'm the only one that can put a stop
to this." And it was like a picture of Ethan Klein's
Yeah, it was. Oh, dude. Totally disavowed. But yes,
cataclysmically funny, unfortunately. Yeah, it is funny. It's
funny to think that like people will get really upset about it,
too. You know, it's a very very credible threat of some kid in
Yemen saying he's going to stop Dothan Klein forever. The terrorists
are after him, the
arguing with people in my chat right Guys, we can do callins.
Guys, you want to come in and argue that uh
you want to argue the doxing thing on Dan's side? You want to
argue of like any critiques of like that was going on tonight?
Hop on the stream. Uh if you want, you can pick who you want
to debate with, that's fine.
I don't need to jump in. But yeah, I don't know. I don't know
how much Listen, if you're a DJ and you're watching this and
you can't believe that all of this happened, okay, you go ahead.
you join the stream, hop on. We'll talk it out cuz realistically
I did not plan very much content for tonight. So,
did you even finish the Melena stuff last night?
No, I didn't. I was. But I didn't. We got like an hour into that.
That was That was going nowhere for a long time. That was That
was like back because she's a total airhead. Let's be serious
No, let's not be serious. Not a total airhead. Come on.
What was Augie's statement? She's like a hippie. She's like a
hippie. She's just like living on her own at her own pace. Okay.
Same thing. She's just chilling. No, not the same thing. You're
like, you're saying you're negatively loading it and I'm just
like, she's just chilling. She's having a good time. She's living
her life. Cleman couldn't imagine. Cleman couldn't imagine just
like waking up on a given day, not making anybody cry or feel
bad about themselves, and then going to sleep and being happy
with your life. Okay. He can't imagine what that would feel like.
Molina's just like, "Hey, I want to put positive energy into
the world. I know if I put positive energy in the world, it'll
come back into my life." Right? And Queen is just like, "If I
don't actually try to make somebody harm themselves, I haven't
lived. I haven't lived." So true. He just doesn't get it. Does
that doesn't feel his blood pumping if I'm not, you know?
The debate with Willie Mack and uh Queman. I think that would
be great. It'd be great for content. They obviously have beef.
like there's been Twitter stuff going on. Why not do it, you
know? That would be really good. Oh, somebody in chat, the Jtock
Gunnar Arc guy, he uh he definitely said some Oh, I think he
said like uh it's tragic that Quimman keeps running from Willy
Mack and won't debate him. I don't know if you saw that, but
uh I thought that was really good. If you saw that, if you saw
that, I feel like he he worded it slightly differently. I was
like that might have gotten him. Maybe if he caught it, that's
Hob.
He might have said something like, "Oh,
didn't Willy Mack debate Hassan? Why is Queenman running from
him?" If if Willy Mack's ready for a challenge or something,
something like that. Okay, Shimu, you're about to witness a treat,
though, cuz I think Queman's like arch nemesis might hop on the
stream to debate with him. Oh god. Wait, which way is it? Kangla.
I actually I actually my [__] There are so there
are so many people who like who like actually just get like super
bitter and angry and are like you guys are lying about everything.
You guys are making all this stuff up and then they won't hop
on the stream. I just wish they'd hop on the stream. There's
got to be a bunch of DJers who are like watching this and seething
but they're too scared to hop on the I try I know I've said a
million times, but it just is so sad that there was like this
you know, the the whole they're meant to be the community of
like back up everything you say and show up on stream and debate
it. That that was the whole thing for years and now it's just
so made and the only people that come on are these like actually
like 70 IQ Indians who are like I don't think
they're Europeans. Lots of Europeans. Lots of Europeans who can't
really count to 25. Unfortunate the Indian the only Indian guy
is the troll
there. One other Indian guy in this community is very smart and
I don't make fun of him because he's actually very very Wait,
that guy's actually Indian. The troll. I thought he was just
like No. No. The troll is not Indian. It's a different Indian
guy. I was going to say Oh, okay. Kathy is not Indian. No, no,
not not Scribble. I'm not talking about Scribbel. Uh, dude, Kangler
said he's going to hop on and he just pieced out. I heard um
Hunter Young's getting on after work, right? Yeah, I doubt it.
I doubt it. But I don't think he was really disagreeing with
us to be honest. He's been No, he's been at work for like I think
he's been at work for like 13 Uhhuh. Uhhuh.
You know who that guy, the one guy was in here again? The man
of the minds guy. I want that guy to join so badly. He was in
here seething last night and he was in here seething again today.
I would love for that guy to join. That would be cool.
He's the guy, remember? He just comes in and like gets he just
doesn't know anything. He's just like he's a guy we got who we
like totally dogwalked when we were watching Relly maybe right
after the stuff popped off. I got banned from DG sub for posting
Indians packing into a train like sardines after scribble about
the Indian birth rate on Destiny's stream. Instantly became an
anti fan.
Okay. Queen's position on the Ethan Klein Denim's chat messages.
Just scroll back and watch it. Leader totally lied about it.
I I don't know. I've spoken about like three times. He completely
lied about it. The clarifications are wanting. I think I think
the clarifications have been wanting. Although, I do think it's
possible that Ethan had a good clarification at some point. I
think when he actually did when he did his statement where he
was basically like kneeling to Denim's uh clarifying his defamation,
I think he might have done it then. But yeah, there was an actual
real clarification from Ethan at some point.
So, yeah, I'm I'm positive. I've seen it was pretty effective.
I mean, I watch quite a bit of this stuff and I like I said,
I didn't know that they had filtered the chat messages at all.
You so many people didn't until like very which is weird because
I I know I brought it up on stream. I know I brought it up when
it like got released. I like looked at it and I was like, "Oh,
this is clearly like and then I saw the like no there's no context
change here and I'm like that's
but I
I feel like people in my community did feel like most of them
had to."
either. So many things so many things were built off of that
too, right? Like uh a lot of the justification for uh the lawsuit
threats or the current ones that are ongoing were was the CPS
stuff, right? Oh, well, he came for the kids. And in that case,
you like built it off of a lie. you know, if you're filtering
those messages and that's not really what was going on. Like
a lot of this stuff would be kind of built on uh deception, you
know, built on
DG did the same thing early on to Ethan saying Hassan's chat
was being anti-Semitic, but they were fake. To be fair, that
was one guy, Mimi DG chat, who like HTML edited a chat message
and he got perma banned for it. Was the Mcaffy antivirus guy.
We all remember that one. Okay, we all remember that one. Okay,
Kingler's here. I'm going to drag him in. See what he's want.
See what he wants to criticize. See what he wants to say. Kingler
92, you're on the stream. We're listening. We're learning.
What's up? What's your What's your criticism today? What do you
want to complain about today? Oh, maybe you don't want me on
that. I'm just curious what the what the your principal disagreement
with Dan's methods are. Why are they bad? Uh that states he will
lie.
Um Oh, okay. Well, that's it. I guess I'll go. No, I just mean
like if it's in service to
uh a goal that you might agree with, Dan has a different principle
than you,
why why why criticize him for doing something that he thinks
is okay? Isn't that kind of like your guy's new outlook? If you
if a person believes from their own perspective that um they
are in the right, then it's hard to criticize them.
no. You You just have to engage with you have to engage. Yeah.
And you have to engage with a justification, right? You have
to pick apart why their argument doesn't work if they're justifying
something they do. I felt like we're doing that. Um Okay. I thought
we talked a few months ago about um how you were you were trying
to be a little bit more charitable to Hassan's side of the internet
and one of the reasons was because you were
um trying to factor in their perspective and and when their
Yeah. So you have to factor that in and engage with that and
pick that apart if you want to condemn what's happening. Right.
If you want to say you're wrong for doing this, you have to explain
why they're wrong for doing it. You can't just say, "Oh, my terrorist
terrorist endlessly and assume everyone's going to go along with
you."
Do you agree with Do you agree with Dan that there's a problem
at Twitch that needs to be addressed? Nope. Oh. Why? Why would
there be a problem that needs to be addressed as a private company
making decisions about the type of content they want on their
platform? They've decided they want lefty content. There's plenty
of platforms where you can be a right-winger that are perfectly
just as profitable as Twitch, if not more. I don't see it there's
a massive injustice or issue happening here.